i think that fraggle rock was different
in its day because it was this giant
puppet extravaganza fraggle rock is a
timeless piece and when you watch it
today it still feels pretty relevant we
all bought into the premise and it
became a life-altering experience it has
remained something that we're proud of
after all these years it was always in
the house we had betamax tapes with
fraggle rock on it it's it's magic
absolute magic there's just something
kind of transporting about the spirit of
the show i just remember the feel of the
music it was so funky it was funny the
characters were authentic to who they
were it was cool and different and it's
really really special i had this like
instantaneous feeling of i have to do
that i want to be part of that
oh we ready
the original fraggle rock is the beating
heart of this series this is not a
complete reinvention it's still very
faithful to the original we knew we
wanted to keep the fraggles we wanted to
keep the doozers and the gorgs and dock
and sprocket but give it a 21st century
update if you go right up close it's a
lot like the original show and if you
pull back it just gets bigger and bigger
and bigger seeing how huge it is took my
breath away
the scripts are so funny not just funny
for kids they are genuinely funny your
mind is going to be
impress it brings a warmth and a
kindness and a sort of sense of
belonging we have an amazing team
working on this series of fraggle rock i
am honored to be back helping continue
the magic we've pulled out all the
puppet stops on fraggle rock there's so
much mechanical creativity on this show
it's magic this is the control which i
operate with my thumb i have never heard
of such a what i have one too wow
the creature shop built a new and
improved junior gorg yeah his face is
just so much more expressive now so you
can get all kinds of really great
movement out of it
you thought i was asleep
i'm a good actor
users were always the most fun the users
in this version of firework are
technologically advanced we're able to
3d print all their accessories doozer
technology is limitless we have a dozer
jet pack
welcome to the 21st century
music is a huge part of fraggle rock and
the original songs were just amazing i
don't know if i can share this but we're
even reusing some of the classic songs
harvey mason jr has just taken that
music and completely reimagined it but
it still feels really familiar and
really accessible
the new songs fit right in line with the
legacy songs so i think you get the best
of both worlds the music is so so good i
find myself singing them all the time
around the house they can't get them out
of my head this is nothing short of a
dream come true
this whole situation is kind of surreal
to me after you oh we're taking
silliness very seriously
john tartaglia is so deeply invested in
his writing he's
producing he's performing he knows
everything about fraggle rock it was
like having a historian in the writers
room with us
you still love i think i need a steaming
hot cup of radish juice it's been a day
oh
working on the original frag rock was so
special i thought i would never
experience it again
but i'm experiencing it here so much i'm
so thrilled being able to acknowledge
the legacy that came before us
and contribute to the future legacy is
pretty monumental fraggle rock was kind
of bold and fearless it touched on some
pretty heavy things sometimes and we're
not shying away from those at all
that's one way that i think we're
honoring jim's vision there is a spirit
about fraggle rock that does constantly
remind me of my father which is this
sort of buoyant optimism that reflects
the way that my father fought and his
philosophy which was there are serious
things in the world but you have the
power to add love into the world
the world needs fraggles i knew it we
need fraggle rock the world has changed
since the original series i would say
that we need frog rock more now than we
did when we first made it that's my cue
it is about understanding and i think
that's really the importance you're not
alone i think audiences are going to be
pretty blown away by how the world looks
how funny the characters are how much
they love each other and how much fun
that is to watch there's really nothing
like this on tv so i was really excited
that it was coming back we have so many
surprises songs games my hope is that
the fans will be transported back to
their childhoods and kids that are
sitting will feel that it's possible to
have a hole in your wall that goes down
fraggle rock
[Music]
you